das virus als brandbeschleuniger nicht
nur im menschlichen körper sondern auch
beim duell der ganz großen
ist das noch gockel verhalten oder schon
gefährliche spielen mit dem feuer wenn
sich peking und washington gegenseitig
beschuldigen die welt mit corona
versorgt zu haben
usa gegen china machtkampf in der korona
krise jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns liebe
zuschauer meine gäste zunächst hier im
studio daniela schwarzer ist direktorin
der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik
shi ming ist freier journalist sie
stammt aus china leben und arbeiten seit
dem ende der 1980 er jahre hier in
deutschland
zugeschaltet aus washington man kollege
elmar theveßen der leiter des dortigen
zdf studios und martin stürmer ist bei
uns auch zugeschaltet virologe sie
leiten ein medizin labor in frankfurt
und vielleicht in dem zusammenhang nicht
unwichtig sie waren im märz an covi 19
also an der korona der krankheit
erkrankt
frau schwarzer bellende hunde beißen ja
bekanntlich nicht gibt das hoffnung in
diesem konflikt der konflikt zwischen
china und den usa geht natürlich weiter
zurück als jetzt die korona krise und
was wir eben im moment sehen ist eine
beschleunigung donald trump provoziert
china schon eine ganze weile und auch
umgekehrt und wir sehen jetzt in einer
art und weise eine eskalation wie
sicherlich auch damit zu tun hat dass
beide innenpolitisch sehr stark unter
druck geraten sind
donald trump hielt ihr ganz großes
geschütz auf der sagt nicht nur das kona
virus käme aus china aus einem labor da
reden wir noch in der sendung darüber
sondern das sei viel schlimmer als pearl
harbour oder als nine eleven kommen
diese attacken von trump eigentlich
china zu passt im moment ist es sehr
widersprüchlich geworden
die ebene auf der china zurück schießt
sinkt ständig er vorher war das
politbüro dann war das außenministerium
dann war s sprecher des
aussenministeriums jetzt ist es nur noch
social media die da schafft
zurückschießen offenbar ist es in der
chinesischen und politische analyse so
dass man trump einerseits ernst nehmen
sollte aber andere sei es nicht
weiterhin provozieren darf weil man bei
ihm nicht fest
voraussagen kann meint er so weit meint
er vielleicht noch viel ernster
es gibt jetzt auch drohungen von bällen
von pompe dass sie in einer rinne ist
ein ehemaliger berater reiko der
außenminister beide sagten dass sie
einen chinesischen überläufer hatten der
dann sehr geheime brisante dokumente
offen legen könnten die also die ich in
dieser richtung noch viel viel
gefährlicher erscheinen lassen kann
das heißt im moment sieht sehe ich eher
so eine widersprüchliche szenario in
peking mann mann versuchte noch nochmal
neue einzuschätzen wie gefährlich traum
wirklich ist gut das ist auch ein
wichtiger bestandteil der sendung jetzt
gleich im athen essen wie sehr
verschenkt denn in den usa
dieser vorwurf dass china der sündenbock
ist also für donald trump ist das ein
ganz wichtiger faktor weil es ihm in
seinem wahlkampf hilft er ist in der tat
in den letzten wochen massiv unter druck
geraten weil man sehr eindeutig belegen
kann dass die tramper administration
viel zu spät reagiert hat auf die
informationen die man doch relativ
frühzeitig schon hatte ganz offenbar
schon im dezember oder november im
vergangenen jahr
und jetzt versucht möglicherweise
abzulenken indem man die schuld auf
china lang aber es ist eben sagt mal da
sitzen zwei im glashaus und schmeißen
mit steinen sowohl die chinesische
regierung als auch die amerikanische und
für donald trump ist das wichtig weil er
weiss genau das kommt bei seinen
anhängern sehr gut an und deswegen geht
sogar die republikanische partei so weit
dass sie ein strategiepapier aufgelegt
hat für den wahlkampf in den nächsten
monaten in dem klar gemacht wird das ist
unser hauptziel den menschen im land
klar zu machen chinas schuld an diesem
virus dann martin stürner es wird ja der
der vorwurf von den amerikanern erhoben
dieses virus sei in einem labor
gezüchtet worden und von dort entwichen
jetzt mal ohne die politischen
hintergründe dieses vorwurfs und dieser
behauptung kann denn dieses virus saß co
2 wie es heißt tatsächlich künstlich
erzeugt werden
labor und dann wenn einer mal nicht
aufpasst sich aus dem staub machen ist
das überhaupt denkbar also in der
theorie ist das denkbar aber wenn wir
uns das realistisch angucken wenn ich
einen virus konstruiere oder besser
machen möchte oder verändern möchte
nämlich ein virus was ich schon kenne
bei auf diesen niveaus auf und verändert
entsprechend in labor und dieses virus
was wir jetzt sehen dass kopf 2 das
basiert nicht auf seinen vorgängern
wieder auf dem normalen coronaviren noch
auf den saas corona die muss was wir aus
2002 2003 kennen insofern ist dieses
künstliche love verbessern und
generieren eher unwahrscheinlich man
sagte dass es ein bisschen ähnlich ist
diesen grippevirus der sogenannten
spanischen grippe von 1918 19 ist das
die eigentliche schwachstelle bei der
bekämpfung des corona virus sondern sagt
man weiß nicht genau wie sie das co2
verhält wie er sich entwickelt weil es
dafür eben keine blaupause gibt ja so
ist es
es mag sich vielleicht ideologisch zu
verhalten wie wie die influenza aber das
sind zwei unterschiedliche virus
familien aber sie hat vollkommen recht
lars koch 2 ist ein neues virus es
verhält sich anders als zum beispiel
auch das sars virus was wir von von
früher erkennen und wir müssen ein
prinzip alles neu lernen und
dementsprechend lisa es ist halt keinen
kleinen künstlichen ursprung ist
natürlich entstanden und wir werden
wahrscheinlich auch im weiteren verlauf
das land über diskutieren wie das
passiert sein kann
mike kompon beruft sich ja auf einen
geheimdienstbericht der sogenannten 515
augen bevor wir da jetzt in den inhalt
gehen wenn wir einen geheimdienst
experten im studio mrt wissen diese 51
da sind ja fünf geheimdienste der fünf
angloamerikanischen ländern usa kanada
vereinigtes königreich australien
neuseeland
was weiß man denn über diesen
geheimdienst verbund ganz generell wie
er arbeitet wofür er steht welche
strategien welche taktik er hat ja
diesen garveys verbunden gibt es seit
jahrzehnten das ist im grunde um ein
gegenseitiges versprechen dieser dienste
dass man die informationen miteinander
teilt die man gesammelt hat das ging
an einer stelle nämlich nach dem 11
september 2001 dann sogar so weit dass
man sich untereinander ab sprach dass
wenn man beschränkt ist in seinem
eigenen land beispielsweise oder in
seiner eigenen region informationen
abzuhören überwachen gesetzlich
beschränkt in irgendeiner weise dass
dann der andere das übernimmt und diese
informationen wiederum mit den anderen
teilt also ein sehr sehr enger verbund
von fünf geheimdiensten und es ist
schwer für andere da hineinzukommen fest
steht dass die beteiligten in dieser
sache tatsächlich hervorragende
aufklärungskapazitäten haben seine
satelliten seines auch menschliche
quellen aber und jetzt kommt das aber
wir wissen aus mehreren quellen hier den
usa dass die amerikaner tatsächlich
schon im november des vergangenen jahres
bei einer untereinheit des pentagon das
gehört auch zum militärischen
geheimnisse unter 1 hunter untereinheit
die nennt sich nationaler medizinischer
nachrichtendienst dass diese einheit
sehr frühzeitig über
satellitenüberwachung schon bemerkt hat
dass sie in haan größeres im gange war
dass das öffentliche leben unterbrochen
wurde und diese informationen wurden
dann innerhalb der amerikanischen
geheimdienste weitergegeben auch zu den
partnern der 51 und auf dieser grundlage
wussten eigentlich alle seit
november/dezember dass da was im busche
war und deswegen kann man vermuten dass
die fivers intensiv seit dieser zeit
eben mit satelliten mit anderen quellen
china überwacht
das wussten die sozusagen vor den
chinesen selbst kann man dazu sagen nein
das glaube ich nicht
ich glaube sie haben veränderungen
festgestellt wir kennen keine details
dazu aber es ging bis zu dem punkt dass
dieser nationale militärische
medizinische nachrichtendienst zu dem
schluss kam es könnte möglicherweise ein
katastrophales ereignis sein spricht der
ausbruch einer krankheit einer pandemie
möglicherweise es ist nie ein richtiger
bericht daraus entstanden aber diese
informationen wurden weitergegeben und
die amerikaner sind davon überzeugt dass
die chinesen zur gleichen zeit
tatsächlich das erlebt haben weil
die dinge die wahrgenommen worden sind
von dem amerikanischen geheimdienst sind
ganz offenbar punkte mit denen ja die
chinesen reagiert hatten auf eine
krankheit auf eine rätselhafte krankheit
die im november mit höchster
wahrscheinlichkeit in wochen aufgetreten
ist der stürmer einer der beteiligten an
diesem bericht ein australier hat gesagt
die wahrscheinlichkeit dieser labor t
silber die wir gerade schon gesprochen
haben die liegt ungefähr bei 5 prozent
das heißt es würde sich ja mit ihren
überzeugungen auch irgendwie decken und
oder gar nicht lang
wir sind hier sind sich die
amerikanischen geheimdienste
da bin ich da noch einsetzen darf
amerikanischen geheimdienste einig mit
auch den 5 es ist extrem
unwahrscheinlich dass dieses virus im
labor erschaffen wurde
aber es gibt eben die vermutung dass
dieses virus möglicherweise
versehentlich aus diesem labor also
nicht künstlich erschaffen aber aus
diesem labor entweichen konnte durch
einen unfall oder ähnliches das halten
die geheimdienste für möglich aber sie
haben auch einige hinweise die dagegen
sprechen
stürmer kann es denn sein dass es
tatsächlich aus diesem labor stammt aber
als natürliches wir uns dann auf diesen
ganz in der nähe liegenden fischmarkt
dann getragen worden ist das ist eine
mögliche verfolgung rückverfolgung des
virus genau der punkt wo ich jetzt auch
ein gehabt hätte das eigentlich die
theorie da nicht so sehr die
neuanschaffung ist sondern dass es im
prinzip ein mehr oder weniger gearteter
unfall ist es gibt nur ein problem in
der hinsicht also probleme in
anführungszeichen die fledermaus viren
um die es ja letztendlich geht die
höchstwahrscheinlich der ursprung
unseres lars koch 2 sind die haben an
einem gen ort verschiedene veränderungen
die wir auch in unserem saß kopf 2 denn
der form auch wiederfinden mehr oder
weniger gleich es gibt aber ein zweiter
veränderung in unserem menschlichen saß
koch 2 die ist in den fledermäusen
überhaupt nicht gibt
dementsprechend ist eigentlich relativ
unwahrscheinlich
durch einen unfall direkt dieses virus
auf die menschheit freigesetzt worden
ist und sich gleich im ersten versuch so
verändert hat dass es eben diese zweite
mutation aktivierter und sich dann
verbreiten konnte sondern als
evolutionär sind da eigentlich immer
mehrere versuche notwendig um thomas
frühjahrs- corona virus gesehen dass
immer wieder tier zu mensch übertragen
das hat sich der menschheit nie
verbreitet weil das virus sich eben im
menschen nicht vernünftig adaptieren
konnte deswegen ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit viel höher
das ist von einer übertragung von
fledermäusen auf einen zwischen wird
gekommen ist und dieser zwischen wird
hat es dann auf den menschen mehrfach
übertragen entsprechend irgendwann hat
sich dann halt auch diese zweite
mutation durchgesetzt und mit diesen
beiden veränderungen letztendlich konnte
das virus sich um menschen zu erreichen
von schwarzer wenn wir das jetzt alles
hören auch was im atelier sind gerade
gesagt hat dass in dem
geheimdienstbericht eigentlich steht
dass es sehr unwahrscheinlich ist und
trotzdem behauptet mit puppe das sei aus
einem labor in hahn und wenn man jetzt
auch höher das offensichtlich druck in
den usa auf die geheimdienste ausgeübt
wird sozusagen für diese behauptung
jetzt die beweise nachzuliefern erinnert
ein bisschen an irak krise und den
irak-krieg 2003 was geht eigentlich in
den in der us-administration gerade vor
wenn sozusagen geheimdienstberichte
diese zunächst mal jetzt eine behauptung
so zurechtgebogen werden
wir haben es mit einem amerikanischen
präsidenten zu tun der es seit
amtsantritt mit der wahrheit nicht
besonders genau nimmt der immer wieder
gelogen hat was ihm auch nachgewiesen
wurde das dokumentiert wurde
es hat seine wähler bislang nicht
wirklich gestört und ich gehe davon aus
dass er diese strategie gerade jetzt wo
die us wahl im november bevorsteht noch
stärker weiterführen wird das heißt er
wird das vertreten wahr oder unwahr was
ihm hilft vielleicht wieder gewählt zu
werden er ist unter druck geraten
die amerikaner haben wegen des sehr
schlechten managements der
gesundheitskrise zum teil das vertrauen
in den präsidenten verloren es gibt eine
enorme polarisierung zwischen den
parteien zwischen dem präsidenten
zwischen den gouverneuren in den staaten
auch über die frage wie mit der pandemie
umgegangen wird und
im moment scheint es mir so dass er die
instrumente die uns bekannt sind die art
und weise wie er in der öffentlichkeit
auftritt auf die spitze treibt und dass
er die geheimdienste nicht besonders
schätzt da gab es schon viele beispiele
wo er ist deutlich gesagt hat es gab
eine eine pressekonferenz mit wladimir
putin wo er gesagt und er traut ihm mehr
als seinen eigenen geheimdiensten das
ist an sich skandalös und das hat auch
damals die wähler nicht gestört insofern
wird er jetzt sicherlich versuchen die
wahrheit sich so hinzubiegen die
geschichte so zu erzählen
auch china versucht den narrativ der
pandemie neu zu schreiben und das tun
sie beide eben auf ihre art die chinesen
können ja ihr glück eigentlich kaum
fassen erst galten sie als die
vertuscher bei der ausbruch der korona
als als die der der virus ausgebrochen
ist galten als vertuscher sind dafür
kritisiert worden ja sogar in der
eigenen bevölkerung was erstaunlich war
für diese schlechte informationspolitik
und jetzt können sich nahezu als opfer
einer entgrenzten us kampagne in der
welt präsentieren ist das für die
chinesen eine art geschenk moment was
trump da an hatte ein geschenk das ist
ein sehr zwiespältiges denn es gibt in
dieser fragestellung zweierlei
kategorien es geht sie in die einen um
den ursprung des des virus und um die
frage wie der virus entwichen ist oder
vielleicht auch von mensch zu von tier
zu mensch von mensch zu mensch
übertragen wird
die zweite kategorie das ist so wie die
politik zumindest anfangen mit mit
dieser solche umgegangen ist
die bleibt unberührt es gibt also jener
von china berichte die belegen dass die
politik selbst sehr früh von dieser
gefährlichen solche wusste und es gibt
jetzt fast ketten lose nachweise dass
also die unteren ebenen aller wirklich
in denen die ordnungsgemäß nach oben
berichtet haben also liegt es daran dass
die politik anders entschieden hat und
zwar die höchste politik und das erklärt
auch warum die chinesische politik so
sehr unter druck geraten ist
warum präsident jean ping so unter druck
geraten ist weil die chinesischen
berichte ist noch nicht einmal die
amerikanischen und französischen oder
irgendwelche anderen berichten die
chinesischen berichte die chinesischen
experten legen offen wie diese kette
ausgesehen hat und ausgesehen haben muss
deswegen gibt es zuerst ein versuch der
chinesischen außenpolitik anderen fass
aufzumachen das ist der fas von virus
ursprung der eigentlich mit der zweiten
kategorie gar nichts zu tun hat also wie
auch immer der virus entstanden ist die
frage ist trotzdem zu klären warum die
politiker anders entschieden hat
die zweite frage ist wie weit kann und
wie man wie weit sollte man die usa
provozieren nicht nur dort sondern auch
die usa auch der demokraten
es ist auch die frage und wenn man jetzt
schon ein geschenk macht wiedergewählt
zu werden wie weit geht das land noch
und die frage ist auch dass die usa die
us militärs jetzt ein aufwind bekommen
also zum beispiel die siebte flotte die
auch ein freak im pazifik
die auch infizierte offiziere haben die
türen auf china die hoffnung wir können
also diese zeitfenster ausnutzen um
taiwan anzugreifen weil die
amerikanische siebter flotter gar nicht
einsatzbereit sein kann und das ist ein
spiel das innerhalb von china sich
hochgeschaukelt und inzwischen mussten
sogar die falken die chinesische armee
auftreten und sagen bitte sei nicht so
naiv der amerikaner sind immer noch
stark genug um uns wirklich hin zurück
ins schwanken
ich habe ich habe ja am anfang diese
unterstellung
noch gemacht dass das ein spiel mit dem
feuer sei kann man denn kann man denn
sagen wer sich dann macht politisch
klüger verhält ich würde sagen das ist
jetzt noch zu früh zu beurteilen denn
wir wissen nicht genau wie weit diese
eskalation geht was wir aus europäischer
sicht beobachten ist das auf seiten der
usa die erwartung wächst dass europa
sich klar positioniert egal wer im
november ins amt gewählt wird demokraten
und republikaner erwarten beide von
europa einen sehr sehr klaren
schulterschluss mit den usa
und das ist für uns natürlich nicht so
leicht obwohl wir in einer gemeinsam
verteidigungsallianz sind obwohl wir
sehr enge handelsbeziehungen mit den usa
haben und vieles mehr ist natürlich das
verhältnis mit china für uns gerade aus
deutscher sicht auch sehr sehr wichtig
aufgrund der sehr engen handels und
sonstigen wirtschaftsbeziehungen und ich
würde sagen die usa versuchen im moment
sehr sehr klar ihre truppen um sich zu
sammeln und gegenüber china position zu
beziehen
aber ob diese strategie aufgeht ist zu
früh zu sagen und wir dürfen auch nicht
unterschätzen dass innerhalb der usa die
pandemie vielleicht ja noch nicht ihre
spitze erreicht hat und dass da noch zu
sehr sehr verschärfen entwicklungen
kommen kann und dann donald trump vor
ganz anderen inneren problemen stehen
wird die motive sind es gibt ja einen
weiteren geheimdienst durch diesmal aus
china und zwar aus einem institut aus
dem chinesischen inlandsgeheimdienst
angeschlossen ist da wird also sozusagen
prognostiziert nach der pandemie könnte
es möglicherweise wir könnten die usa
möglicherweise sogar einen militärischen
konflikt provozieren gegenüber china
wird so etwas in den usa ernst genommen
was ist da dran ist das nur säbel
rasseln oder ist das auch ein signal an
washington
irgendwo ist eine rote linie die er
nicht überschreiten dürfe also ich
glaube schon dass es solche stimmen oder
überlegungen gibt auch im beraterkreis
von donald trump aber nicht unbedingt er
selber jeder ist sich im klaren darüber
dass eine militärische
auseinandersetzung zwischen china und
den usa beiden seiten nicht hilft im
gegenteil donald trump ist eigentlich
sogar angewiesen darauf dass er
ein handeln in sachen wirtschaft mit
china wege findet seine handels stils
weiter voranzutreiben
der letzte der ja im januar
unterschrieben worden ist der face
handel so nennt man den phase 1 diehl
der sollte ja gefolgt werden von einem
zweiten handels fiel um eben bessere
rahmenbedingungen herauszuschlagen auch
für die amerikanischen pharma für die
amerikanische industrie und so weiter
donald trump wäre eher daran gelegen
dass er china zwar unter druck setzt
also einen langen hebel in der hand hat
um vielleicht zu ergebnissen in diesen
handelsgesprächen zu kommen
aber er ist glaube ich nicht an einem
krieg gelegen es gibt einige andere
falken die der meinung sind das ist die
große auseinandersetzung der zukunft
china gegen die usa und umgekehrt ein
krieg der sich nicht notwendigerweise in
einem unmittelbaren militärischen
konflikten niederschlägt dafür wird man
das prinzip der abschreckung in den
nächsten jahren weiterhin vorantreiben
also was die entsprechende rüstung
angeht sondern eher ein krieg der im
wirtschaftsbereich im technischen
bereich stattfindet und da gibt es
starke kräfte innerhalb der
republikanischen aber auch der
demokratischen partei die ganz klar
machen china ist der große widersacher
der usa für die nächsten jahrzehnte
stimmt es dass manche us-unternehmen
sauer sind auf diese
eskalationsstrategie von trump weil sie
sagen jetzt durch das kona virus ist die
inländische wirtschaft auf talfahrt
jetzt vermasselt unser präsident auch
noch das ost asien geschäft indem er
eben sich mit china in dieser weise an
liegt absolut das hat er aber vorher
auch schon gemacht durch seinen
handelskrieg mit china hat er dafür
gesorgt dass viele große amerikanische
unternehmen so viel unsicherheit hatten
dass sie auch nicht investiert haben
da wo es dringend notwendig gewesen wäre
in den letzten jahren mann war dann froh
dass es endlich einen handels die gibt
er allerdings sagen wir mal auch nicht
so viel besser aussieht als das was man
vorher schon einmal vereinbart hatte
und jetzt kommt eben obendrauf eine
mögliche neue eskalation in der
situation wo amerika 33 millionen
arbeitslose zu gefragten beklagen hat
wo die wirtschaft auf der talfahrt ist
da sagen sicherlich einige große
konzerne allerdings hinter vorgehaltener
hand sie stellen sich nicht offen gegen
donald trump dass das was da gerade
passiert nicht im interesse der
amerikanischen wirtschaft stürmer sind
die amerikaner auf china denn auch zum
beispiel angewiesen oder ist man
vielleicht sogar aufeinander angewiesen
nicht zuletzt bei der bekämpfung der
kroner krise des kroner virus der
krankheit auch bei der suche nach einem
impfstoff bei medizinischer
schutzausrüstung inwieweit sind auch die
amerikaner abhängig von china wie
wichtig ist china für die produktion all
dieser medizinischen produkte ja ich
denke schon dass es da gewisse
abhängigkeiten gibt wobei man natürlich
jetzt versucht darf und eben dieses
mangels thema ja dann doch auf dem markt
gesehen hat gerade an schutzausrüstung
in eigenregie alles mögliche zu
produzieren und ich denke man hat auch
gemerkt dass es durchaus gefährlich sein
kann sich in eine solche abhängigkeit zu
geben
ich glaube was die impfstoffentwicklung
und die medikamentenentwicklung angeht
sind wir doch relativ unabhängig von
china das medikament was er jetzt in
studien läuft wird den usa produziert
wird von der firma einer us-firma
gelehrt auch den markt gebracht wenn die
studienlage günstig aussieht
die studien laufen auch außerhalb von
china und dass die impfstoffe
entwicklung angeht sehe ich da auch er
die möglichkeiten und dass wir das so
abhängig von china auch bewerkstelligen
können
wenn jetzt die wirtschaft und
medizinischen bereich nicht so sehr
verflochten ist politisch und
militärisch ist china mit den usa eng
verflochten es gibt einen gemeinsamen
interesses raum also den bereich asien
pazifik wie gefährlich könnte es denn
dort werden
da sind ja noch eine ganze reihe sagte
reiber hand schon genannt worden
es gibt noch andere länder die auch mit
china im konflikt den philippinen
vietnam zum beispiel japan südkorea
braut sich da was zusammen
die gefahr einer militärischen
eskalation wird seit einigen jahren
besprochen und seit trump an der macht
es umso mehr
im moment sind wir wieder
einer phase wo die sehr schwarzen
szenarien greifbare erscheinen aber ich
glaube was schon vor zwei drei jahren
galt gilt jetzt immer noch an einer
militärischen eskalation in dem gebiet
kann keiner der beiden wirklich ein
interesse haben die kosten sind
ungeheuer hoch für beide seiten und ich
glaube auch nicht dass trumps kalkül
sinnvollerweise sein kann dass er in
einem kriegszustand
in der asien pazifik region sein
wahlkampf erfolgreicher führen kann
unter den bedingungen der pandemie die
im moment in den usa herrschen also ich
glaube es in der tat dass die konflikt
spirale sich weiterdreht aber eben mit
nicht militärischen mitteln und was wir
sehen ist wir haben eine ein hippie
moden der an macht verliert die usa ja
als aufstrebende weltmacht mit einer
ganz ganz klar formulierten ambitionen
die man nachlesen kann in den
offiziellen dokumenten also seine
politische und seine wirtschaftliche
macht auszubauen auszuweiten
das tut china seit einigen jahren auch
deutlich für uns spürbar in europa und
die usa reagieren darauf und es ist in
der geschichte der weltgeschichte immer
wieder so gewesen dass ein hegemon der
an macht und einfluss verliert wirklich
sehr um sich schlägt und versucht an
dieser macht festzuhalten oder man
trotzdem wenn ich das beendet ist das
rationale kalkül was ich glaube was bei
so großen militärischen fragen immer
noch eine rolle spielt trotz allem was
ihr über trump schon gesagt haben ist
sehr sehr deutlich dass der preis für
die usa ungeheuer große weil dieser
konflikt wäre nicht zeitlich klar zu
begrenzen regional nicht einzudämmen das
ist ein sehr unkontrollierbares gesicht
wenn sie sagen nicht militärische
konflikt spirale das wird immer stärker
das wird immer heftiger ist dass
irgendwann mal an dem punkt wo es dann
auch militärisch werden kann
das ist natürlich nicht auszuschließen
aber wie gesagt ich glaube dass bei so
einer großen entscheidung dann auch
wieder für trump die innenpolitik eine
große rolle spielt da sein ziel ist es
wieder gewählt zu werden
und wenn man sich die öffentliche
meinung anschaut ist schon auch seit
jahren einen trend
deutlich geworden nämlich dass die
bevölkerung kein interesse mehr daran
hat dass die usa international
militärisch aktiv ist und das
amerikanische soldaten irgendwo sterben
und sosehr trump im moment den er aktiv
braucht dass china ein feindbild ist und
dass er derjenige ist der die usa vor
diesen feind schützt und letztendlich
auch eine art krieg gegen den virus hat
er auch gesagt führt das brauche als
negativ aber meiner einschätzung nach
hier aus der ferne würde ich sagen ein
militärischer konflikt bringt in seinen
zielen nicht mehr geschminkt das ist
also ein schon länger schwelender
konflikt zwischen den usa und china der
jetzt durch das auftreten des corona
wäre sozusagen noch weiter verschärft
wird wenn man jetzt auch das was wir
vorher schon gesprochen haben zum
ausbruch der groner des corona
viruserkrankungen der epidemie und
später der pandemie ende letzten jahres
und anfang dieses jahres schon
gesprochen haben die da gab es in china
auch in politische konflikte aber dieses
verhalten von trump hat das jetzt zu
solidarisierungseffekt eingeführt
zwischen der bevölkerung und der partei
in china die eigentlich ja trump gar
nicht beabsichtigt hatte
ich glaube das bild ist viel viel
komplexer als eben dass man sagen kann
gehen die beiden auf andern dazu die
gesellschaft mehr und die führungen die
gesellschaft ist so sehr gespalten dass
verschiedene signale sofort auch sehr
unterschiedlich interpretiert werden
also jetzt ohne die usa zb die
entschädigungsforderungen aus europa aus
italien der slowakei aus spanien aus
belgien aus verschiedenen seiten die sie
zupfen so viel an die ich inzwischen
nerven weil sie merken jetzt kommen wir
etwas großes auf uns so auch ohne die
usa
der afrikaner die jetzt mit 55
botschaftern bei den chinesischen
aussenministeriums vorstellig geworden
sind wegen die diskriminierung der
afrikaner in südchina die drohen jetzt
schon
sie fordern von china einen
schuldenerlass auf 100 pro 100 prozent
also 200 milliarden dollar und da gibt
es noch von lat amerikanischen seite von
nicole von von von ecuador von venezuela
von brasilien von argentinien langsam
auch so die stimmungen also das amt ist
eine der wichtigsten symbolfiguren aber
er ist nicht mehr der einzige
insofern ist es dann schon auch eine
stimmung in der chinesischen
gesellschaft die dann sagen wer hatte
eigentlich das alles für uns eingebrockt
es ist nur der defekte und trüben oder
sitzen bei uns auch noch ein paar leute
die da eigentlich falsche dinge drehen
also es gibt jetzt eine starke
diskussion ob man messen
nationalistischen stimmungen noch hoch
führen sollten damit die gesellschaft
zusammenhält oder ob man diese stimmung
eher ein thema muss weil ja wenn wir
weiterhin feinde gewalt machen wo enden
dass roma zu dem deutschen zu kommen die
deutschen gehören noch zu den
beliebtesten rivalen also zumindest bei
der person trump keine kunst naja gut
also beim mars zum beispiel wurde zuerst
gelobt weil er gesagt hatte wir sind
eigentlich nicht so überzeugt von der
amerikanische argumentation am nächsten
tag sagt aber maße wir fordern und von
chinesischen seite mehr transparenz und
sofort wurde auf dem mars beschimpft ja
was was willst du eigentlich mit
transparent wir sind doch so transparent
wir sind schon glas münchen für euch ihr
habt also früh genug die warnung
bekommen was sollte irgendwo was wollte
dir also diese mehrstimmige nervosität
nicht mehr allein auf usa die ist neu
die ist nicht mehr so zu kontrollieren
von der partei dass man sagen kann wir
schießen uns auf einen feind und sofort
ist die gesellschaft bei mir und das
macht natürlich auch die wirtschaften
müssen nicht mehr mit weil diese
entkopplung die nicht nur von den usa
betrieben wird sondern auch von japan
japan stellte große kredite zur
verfügung um damit die japanischen
unternehmen auf regierungs kosten sich
zurückziehen können aus china und die
bundesregierung hat jetzt das gesetz für
außenhandel und bezahlungssystem
geändert und kontrolliert so viel mehr
die ausländische investitionen die ihnen
in deutschland firmen aufkaufen
das sind also signale wo die
chinesischen intellektuellen auch die
chinesischen elite es anfangen sich und
die politik zu fragen ja wie sollen wir
eigentlich mit diesen komplexen
situationen umgehen reicht es uns ist
die usa noch zum feind zu machen und bin
ja auch noch nicht mal entschlossen seit
mit den usa wirklichen krieg anzufangen
also druck bitte nicht so laut und
wünsche und drohen dann bitte an gute
hielt ein stichwort aufnehmen
heiko maas heiko maas beschimpfen ist im
moment gerade in mode er hat ja den us
außenminister einen brief geschrieben
und gebeten das zu überdenken aus der
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
auszutreten frau schwarzer hat er einen
antwortbrief bekommen dagegen pompeo gar
nicht auf diesen wunsch ein sondern er
hat mehr oder minder heimlich gesagt
reiko du wirst uns doch unterstützen
beim kampf um die freiheit und gegen den
bösen buben in china ist es
symptomatisch für das transatlantische
verhältnis was wir da bei dieser zusagen
bei diesen kleinen schlenker aus der
globalen diskussion heraus erleben das
ist genau der druck von dem ich vor
entsprach das die amerikaner klare
erwartungen an nicht nur in deutschland
sondern an die europäer formulieren sich
an die seite der usa zu stellen
weil den möglichen streitpunkt dies mit
china gibt aber noch etwas anderes
symptomatisches liegt in dem
antwortschreiben nämlich der rückzug der
usa aus globalen ordnungsstrukturen und
nun gerade in dieser situation die
finanzierung für die
weltgesundheitsorganisation zu kappen
ist letztendlich eine fortführung von
drums politik die unmittelbar nach
amtsantritt begonnen hat umzusetzen und
schon im wahlkampf angekündigt hatte
dass sie versuchen alle möglichen
internationalen organisationen zu
schwächen und die amerikanischen
beiträge zu diesen zu reduzieren
und jetzt ist tatsächlich deutschland
mit seinem starken anspruch und
interesse multilaterale
ordnungsstrukturen gerade in dieser
situation wieder zu stärken
darauf angewiesen dass es andere partner
findet mit denen es gemeinsam das nötige
tun kann was gerade jetzt akut im
krisenfall nötig ist um die pandemie zu
bekämpfen und deshalb gab es unter
anderem in dieser woche die
geberkonferenz der ursula von der leyen
die europäische kommissionspräsidentin
vorsaß um knapp 8 milliarden euro oder
dollar zu zu mobilisieren um
letztendlich das nötige zu tun
unter anderem im bereich der impfstoff
entwicklung und der entwicklung von
medikamenten und da schließen sich dann
weitere fragen an die unbedingt
international kooperativ geklärt werden
müssen nämlich nicht nur die frage wo
kommt das geld ja um das zu entwickeln
sondern am ende auch die
verteilungsfrage und es ist wohl richtig
dass wir nicht von den chinesen abhängig
sind in der entwicklung dieser produkte
aber auch innerhalb der westlichen
allianz ist es denkbar dass verteilungs
streitigkeiten aufkommen und das wäre
natürlich sehr gut deshalb gibt es auch
die initiative die bundespräsident
steinmeier mit gestartet hat dass man
letztendlich impfstoff und medikament zu
einer art öffentlichen gut erklärt
gemeinsam an seiner entwicklung arbeitet
und sich vorher gedanken macht wie man
die verteilung fair organisieren kann
auf den aspekt komme gleich nochmal
zurück im aktivisten aus dem verhältnis
berlin/washington also auf der
politischen ebene wird im verlauf der
ersten präsidentschaft von trump
zumindest noch bis november
wohl nichts mehr werden oder die haben
wir jetzt auch diese diskussion über den
brief maß an den briefwechsel maß pompeo
anzieht ja ich glaube die brüche in ich
sag mal einem gemeinsamen wertesystem
das klingt sehr weitgehende das ist so
zwischen der tramp administration und
den regierungen in europa die sind noch
viel größer geworden in den letzten
jahren und jetzt gerade sehen wir
eigentlich das ergebnis ist absolut
richtig dass die trump administration
schon seit jahren der meinung ist dass
man globale probleme nicht mit
multilateralen vereinbarungen löst
sondern immer nur im bilateralen
zwischen einzelnen staaten und dann geht
es in erster linie darum deals zu machen
handels deals die wirtschaftliche
vorteile bringen für die vereinigten
staaten
und ich will hier noch einmal klar sagen
dass dieser bruch in dem wertesystem
nicht notwendigerweise etwas ist
zwischen den bevölkerungen hier in den
usa und dann in europa sondern das
spielt sich wirklich absolut auf der
politischen ebene rund um trump ab und
vor diesem hintergrund hat er in den
vergangenen jahren alle
verteidigungslinien aufgegeben die mann
hatte um globale gesundheitsprobleme zu
bekämpfen er hat in der tat schon
massive kürzungen vorgenommen bei der
whu bei amerikanischen einrichtungen die
weltweit bei diesem frühwarnsystem
geholfen haben darunter auch das cdc das
ist die solchen kontrollbehörde die
weltweit im einsatz war übrigens auch in
china
da sind die büros teilweise verringert
verkleinert oder dicht gemacht worden
die amerikanische stellen dort
unterhielten damit war das
frühwarnsystem absolut fit und insofern
hat er die geister selber gerufen mit
denen er momentan gerade kämpft was
bedeutet das für das verhältnis usa
deutschland ich glaube solange trump im
amt ist wird sich das nicht verbessern
und verändern
die deutschen wissen sehr genau dass sie
mit anderen partnern versuchen müssen
die probleme zu lösen das tut die
bundeskanzlerin ja auch wenn man bei g7
oder g20 gipfeln ist merkt man dass die
versuche probleme zu lösen nicht die usa
von vorneherein mit einschließen man
lädt sie immer mit ein
aber weiß eigentlich schon im vorhinein
dass trump mit höchster
wahrscheinlichkeit ablehnen wir reden
über die nicht nur über die
international auch über die bienen
konflikte in den usa hat corona das zeug
die usa und die gesellschaft der usa
noch sehr viel tiefer zu spalten als sie
jetzt schon gespalten ist
ja das ist absolut der fall wir erleben
das jetzt also das potenzial ist da es
dazu kommt müssen wir sehen wie erleben
das jetzt dass viele bundesstaaten die
geschäfte wieder öffnen die wirtschaft
wieder ins laufen kommt obwohl diese
bundesstaaten in überwältigender
mehrheit nicht die kriterien erfüllen
nach denen mediziner eine vorsichtige
öffnung empfehlen das heißt es läuft
hier jeder einzelne bundesstaat ein
großes risiko dass die zahlen in die
höhe schnellen werden in den nächsten
monaten
und das dürfte die polarisierung im land
dann noch einmal verstärken
es ändert aber nichts daran dass die
wirtschaftliche situation der usa eben
diese wiedereröffnung fast erzwungen hat
denn die lage ist dramatisch wir haben
mittlerweile über 33 millionen menschen
die sich arbeitslos gemeldet haben und
das was wir hier in der korona krise
erleben offenbart im grunde genommen
alle probleme und alle brüche innerhalb
des landes was eine soziale ungleichheit
angeht was seine wirtschaftliche
ungleichheit angeht menschen ohne
krankenversicherung ein schlecht
funktionierendes gesundheitssystem das
unglaublich viel geld beinhaltet
eigentlich aber offenbar nicht die
leistungen liefert die eine so große
nationen wie die usa brauchen und dann
natürlich die politische polarisierung
das heißt alle brüche werden durch das
virus offengelegt und die große und
entscheidende frage ist eben die wahl im
november wird sie dazu führen dass
jemand ins amt kommt ja versucht das
land zu vereinen die menschen wieder
zusammenzubringen im eindruck der krise
so wie es frühere präsidentin
kriegspräsidenten teilweise ja auch
geschafft haben oder wird donald trump
wiedergewählt der ja in diesen tagen
jede gelegenheit nutzt um den teil noch
tiefer in diese gesellschaft zu tragen
indem er selbst bewaffnet
proteste hier in den usa gegen die haus
gegen die ausgangssperren unterstützt
uns in diesem zusammenhang von guten
leuten redet die halt nur ein bisschen
was glauben sie wird
trump das thema china oder feindbild
china ist es wird dass das
wahlkampfthema nummer eins werden dass
auch am meisten zieht von dem er sich am
meisten verspricht als für einen
wahlerfolg am dritten november
er hat momentan nicht viel andere themen
das ist sicher das thema von dem er sich
am meisten verspricht aber gleichzeitig
das will ich noch mal wiederholen hatte
ein riesiges problem er muss eigentlich
mit china weiter im wirtschafts- und
handelsbereich vorankommen
denn zb der deal der im januar gemacht
worden ist der liegt ja gewissermaßen
jetzt auf eis wo an wen sollen denn die
soja farmer in den usa ihre produkte
verkaufen wenn die das verhältnis
zwischen china und usa sich weiterhin
dramatisch verschlechtert deswegen würde
ich eher darauf tippen dass er mit sehr
viel wort getöse versucht den hebel zu
vergrößern um zu fortschritten zu kommen
in diesen handels und wirtschaftsfragen
und dass er am ende nicht bereit ist es
sich nie es zum äußersten kommen zu
lassen also wirklich einen konflikt mit
china heraufzubeschwören der am ende
dazu führt dass die wirtschaftliche
situation in den usa noch schlechter
wird
daher stellen wir jetzt ist fantasy wir
ein impfstoff der glaube ich gegen ebola
gegen das ebola fieber in afrika
entwickelt worden ist auch gar nicht so
wirksam dort glaube ich war es und jetzt
zugelassen worden als mögliches
bekämpfung als wirkliches medikament
gegen gegen hof sei es 262 also die das
virus von corona ist es das
allheilmittel gibt es da eine chance
dass das möglicherweise zumindest bis
zur entwicklung eines richtigen
impfstoffs von den usa oder auch von
anderen ländern das schlimmste abhält
nein es ist ein medikament das
tatsächlich
zur von der epidemie pandemie entwickelt
worden ist und auch getestet worden
das grund einige virus mechanismen sich
tatsächlich doch ähneln auch wenn es
andere familien sind insofern wirkt es
wohl auch sehr gut
bei saas kopf 2 wir haben
studienergebnisse aus den usa gesehen da
war es erfolgreich die krankenhaus
aufenthalt von schwer erkrankten
patienten zu reduzieren von 15 auf 11
tage
wir haben aber gesehen dass die
sterblichkeit sich nicht großartig
verändert es gab zwar einen trend zu
einer geringeren sterblichkeit das war
aber nicht signifikant
es gab eine zweite studie die in china
gelaufen ist die hat keine guten
ergebnisse gezeigt die es aber
abgebrochen worden weil die
patientenzahl zu bewegen war und studien
müssen eine ausreichende patientenzahl
haben damit die daten tatsächlich
vernünftig auswertbar sind kein
allheilmittel wird es nicht sein es kann
den krankheitsverlauf bei erkrankten
mildern aber es ist definitiv nicht
dafür geeignet und sozusagen
prophylaktisch in reiner form zu helfen
nicht erkannt nicht sich zu infizieren
dafür ist es definitiv nicht geeignet
jetzt kriegt man ja außer dem handy so
im abstand von zwei stunden push
meldungen dass irgendwo impfstoff
möglicherweise erfolgversprechend
getestet wird das antikörper test gibt
die auch erfolgversprechend sind bei
dieser ganzen diskussion wer hat denn da
im moment eigentlich bei der entwicklung
eines wirklich wirksamen impfstoffes die
nase fahren oder lässt sich das gar
nicht sagen
nein das lässt sich so nicht sagen es
ist viele firmen dran die die impfstoffe
entwickeln und auch testen wir haben ja
schon es ist schon ein bisschen länger
in den usa eine patientin gehabt die
diesen impfstoff schon mal bekommen um
die verträglichkeit überhaupt zu prüfen
vor wenigen tagen ist in deutschland
eine studie gestartet mit einem auch in
deutschland entwickelten impfstoff wo
erst mal die verträglichkeit getestet
wird also auf der ganzen welt laufen
diese studien an und ich glaube es ist
auch gut so dass wir später nicht einen
impfstoff haben werden sondern mehrere
impfstoffe so dass eben auch nicht so
eine art monopol und möglicherweise
andere mechanismen greifen werden die
letztendlich doch immer wieder zu
befürchten sind aber wir müssen uns
gedulden das wird sicherlich noch ein
paar tage dauern
ich rechne nicht vor anfang nächsten
jahres mit einem zugelassenen impfstoff
ich vermute dass mit anderen mechanismen
meisten die verteilungskämpfe wenn dann
der impfstoff tatsächlich auf dem markt
es stehen uns die noch erst recht bevor
die verteilungskämpfe um den impfstoff
wenn er da ist
und da werden ja die verteilungskämpfe
kämpfer haben sich ja in diesen tagen ja
schon mal an kleineren beispielen
gezeigt zum beispiel mundschutz-masken
beatmungsmaschine test setzte überall
und wir haben doch gar nicht das thema
afrika begonnen nun ein tag minuten
deswegen könnte das gar nicht mehr
anfangen
ja also das aber jetzt zu machen kurz
gesagt diese diese erpresserische
dominanz eines staates egal welches
staates diesen natürlich genauso
bedrohlich wie die solche selbst auch ja
also deswegen denke ich werden auch die
usa und china daran gemessen um sie
wirklich noch bereit sind mit der welt
zu teilen
ich weiß in gefahr frau schweizer für
die internationale ordnung was da auf
uns zukommen könnte oder über das jetzt
übertrieben was den impfstoff angeht
nein ich sehe diese verteilungskämpfe
zwischen staaten innerhalb von
gesellschaften auch die frage ist welche
gesellschaftliche gruppe hat das anrecht
die ersten impfstoffe oder die erste
möglichkeit zu impfen wahrzunehmen
aber und das ist der letzte satz von mir
afrika ist in der tat ein riesenthema
und deshalb ist es so wichtig dass man
hier versteht dass die pandemie nur
wirksam eingedämmt werden kann wenn wir
das auch in unserer nachbarschaft tun
und afrika wenn da nicht genug getan
wird um die pandemie einzudämmen ist für
uns die große gefahr dass wir nicht nur
dort einen die stabilisierten kontinent
sehen sondern auch ein wieder import der
pandemie zu einem späteren zeitpunkt im
at wissen letzte frage sollte der
impfstoff als erstes in den usa
entwickelt werden habe die anderen
länder der welt wenig hilfe zu erwarten
ist das richtig also trump hatte
versprochen dass er bis jahresende dann
300 millionen dosen schon für amerikaner
zur verfügung stellt da bliebe nicht
viel für andere über am ende ist die
frage ob die welt zusammen kommt und
nicht die autoritären regime gegen die
liberalen demokratien da an kämpfen ich
glaube das ist die große dahinter
liegende frage und ich glaube wir wissen
alle aus den erfahrungen der letzten
monate eigentlich lässt sich das problem
nur
gemeinsam lösen und nicht gegeneinander
ich bedanke mich für ihre anwesenheit
bei el mati wissen bei martin stürmer
hat daniela schwarzer und bei chieming
liebe zuschauer so weit die phoenix
runde
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]